ya hablamos un poco sobre cómo podemos
utilizar una curva de posibilidades de
producción para ilustrar el concepto de
crecimiento económico vamos a repasar
qué es el crecimiento económico y luego
profundizaremos en las ventajas y
desventajas que para un país tiene la
producción de distintos tipos de bienes
en el presente y cómo pueden afectar su
nivel de crecimiento económico en el
futuro recordarás que el crecimiento
económico se define como un incremento
en la capacidad de producción de bienes
y servicios de un país en un determinado
periodo de tiempo
recordemos que en una curva de
posibilidades de producción podemos
ilustrar el crecimiento económico como
un desplazamiento hacia afuera de la
curva de posibilidades de producción de
un país a lo largo del tiempo en esta
gráfica mostraremos el crecimiento
económico como un desplazamiento de la
curva blanca hacia la curva rosa esto
representa un aumento en la capacidad de
un país para producir los bienes
mostrados en la curva de posible
desde producción a lo largo del tiempo
queremos saber cuáles son las causas del
crecimiento económico y como la decisión
de un país respecto a cómo distribuir
sus recursos en el presente afecta su
nivel de producción potencial en el
futuro para ayudarnos a responder esta
pregunta coloquemos dos diferentes tipos
de bienes en nuestra curva de
posibilidades de producción el patito de
hule en el eje vertical representa lo
que llamaremos bienes de consumo el
tractor en el eje horizontal es una
herramienta que se utiliza para producir
productos agrícolas es un bien que se
utiliza para producir más bienes que la
sociedad necesita a este tipo de
herramientas se les conoce como bienes
de capital antes de continuar definamos
qué son los bienes de consumo y los
bienes de capital el patito de hule
representa los bienes de consumo que son
bienes destinados para su venta a los
hogares estos bienes se consumen y luego
se desechan
en cambio los bienes de capital son
bienes que se venden a las empresas y se
usan para producir más bienes por lo
tanto si un país asigna más recursos
para la producción de bienes de capital
en el presente básicamente está
eligiendo producir más bienes y
servicios en el futuro a cambio de
producir menos bienes y servicios
actualmente volvamos a la curva blanca
de posibilidades de producción
supongamos que representa las
posibilidades de producción actuales de
un país hipotético si ese país elige
producir más bienes de consumo podría
colocarse en el punto a donde produce
más patitos de hule pero su costo de
oportunidad serían los bienes de capital
es decir las herramientas que estaría
dejando de producir si el país se elige
a asignar sus recursos para la
producción de más bienes de capital en
el presente podría colocarse en el punto
b lo cual quiere decir que su costo de
oportunidad sería producir menos bienes
de consumo observa que para desplazar
del punto a al punto b el país está
dejando de producir todos estos patitos
de hule los cuales podría haber
producido si hubiera elegido producir en
el punto a este es el costo de
oportunidad de producir en el punto b
ahora bien qué sucede si el país se
mueve en la otra dirección y decide
producir más bienes de consumo en el
presente en otras palabras qué sucede si
se desplaza del punto b al punto a en
ese caso el costo de oportunidad serían
los bienes de capital que deja de
producir al desplazarse al punto a
recuerda que la curva de posibilidades
de producción ilustra la idea básica del
costo de oportunidad nos muestra una
cosa que se deja de producir para
producir otra analicemos ahora las
consecuencias que tendría para este país
elegir producir en el punto a o elegir
producir en el punto b qué sucede si
decide asignar más recursos para
producir bienes de consumo en el
presente básicamente lo que está
eligiendo es consumo presente
con sumo futuro y qué quiere decir esto
en esencia si el país produce en el
punto a está dejando de producir los
bienes de capital que podría haber
utilizado para producir otros bienes en
el futuro por lo tanto el país está
eligiendo un nivel de vida más alto en
el presente en vez de un nivel de vida
más alto en algún momento del futuro
comparemos esto con el punto b en la
curva de posibilidades de producción si
el país decide asignar más recursos para
producir bienes de capital en el
presente está eligiendo consumo futuro
sobre consumo presente qué quiere decir
esto al asignar una mayor cantidad de
recursos a la producción de bienes de
capital como herramientas equipo y
tecnologías que puedan utilizarse para
producir otros bienes en el presente el
país está renunciando al consumo
presente que podría disfrutar si
produjera más bienes de consumo sin
embargo es probable que el beneficio de
producir más bienes de capital en el
presente sea tener tasas de crecimiento
económico más altas en el futuro esto es
así porque los bienes de capital se
utilizan para producir más bienes y el
capital es un factor de producción los
bienes de consumo no son un factor de
producción a la gente le gusta tenerlos
y es divertido jugar con ellos pero
finalmente se consumen y se desechan en
cambio los bienes de capital no se
desechan tan rápidamente se usan en las
fábricas en los campos en las minas y se
utilizan de todas las distintas maneras
en que producimos bienes y servicios que
benefician a la sociedad al asignar más
recursos para producir bienes de capital
en el presente un país está eligiendo
consumo futuro sobre consumo presente
para ilustrar este concepto veamos
algunos datos reales que muestran la
manera en que dos países decidieron
asignar sus recursos para la producción
en el presente luego vamos a comparar
sus tasas de crecimiento económico en
los últimos 15 años para mostrar que uno
de esos países
efectivamente expert
y un mayor crecimiento económico vamos a
ver los datos aquí tenemos información
sobre la producción de dos países -china
a la izquierda y eeuu a la derecha
primero observemos el caso de china en
el 2016 china invirtió el 43.7 por
ciento de su producto interno bruto
total esto quiere decir que 43.7 de cada
100 dólares gastados en china se
utilizaron en bienes de capital
comparemos esto con su nivel de consumo
sólo el 37.1 por ciento de su gasto
total se destinó al consumo doméstico
china eligió asignar más recursos para
la producción de bienes de capital que
para la producción de bienes de consumo
ahora veamos el caso de eeuu en el 2016
sólo el 15.9 por ciento del gasto total
de eeuu se destinó a bienes de capital
en cambio el 68.6 por ciento de su gasto
total se dedicó al consumo doméstico
básicamente esto
a dos unidos eligió los patitos de hule
en vez de los tractores es decir los
bienes de consumo en vez de los bienes
de capital aunque esto no es lo único
que afecta a la tasa de crecimiento
económico de un país si observamos las
tasas de crecimiento económico reales de
china y eeuu desde el año 2000 surge un
dato muy interesante
china ha disfrutado de tasas de
crecimiento económico significativamente
más elevadas la línea azul representa la
tasa de crecimiento económico de china
desde el 2000 hasta el 2015 podemos ver
que tiene un crecimiento promedio de
entre el 8% y el 14% por año esto quiere
decir que cada año su economía ha
producido aproximadamente un 10% más de
productos que el año anterior
comparémoslo con eeuu cuya tasa de
crecimiento tiene un promedio
significativamente más bajo de entre
menos 2% y 4% eeuu ha conseguido tener
un crecimiento
económico durante la mayor parte de los
últimos 15 años pero su tasa de
crecimiento económico fue bastante menor
que la de china
evidentemente china tiene una población
mucho más numerosa además se encuentra
en un nivel de desarrollo económico más
bajo que eeuu por lo que tiene más
opciones de crecimiento china también ha
elegido a invertir más cantidades de sus
recursos en bienes de capital que en la
producción de bienes de consumo para los
hogares volviendo a nuestra curva de
posibilidades de producción este hecho
respalda la idea de que al elegir
producir más bienes de capital en el
presente un país está eligiendo
básicamente consumo futuro sobre consumo
presente el crecimiento económico tiene
diversas causas que los economistas han
estado analizando desde hace 200 años el
incremento de la población el incremento
del nivel de educación el nivel de
habilidad la cantidad de tecnología y la
disponibilidad de recursos son causas
importantes
el crecimiento económico sin embargo la
decisión de un país sobre cómo asigna
sus recursos para la producción en el
presente también repercute sobre su tasa
de crecimiento económico nos vemos en
otro vídeo